i am so excited to interview you again
every time i interview you
you are always such a standoff the first
time i interviewed you you were on the
floor in a closet with your sunglasses
on and a hoodie on that's beautiful now
you don't have a shirt so we had a hard
time putting a mic on you so we gave you
the fancy one i have i have the fancy
mic yeah um i just came off stage and
then
yeah now i'm here how are you feeling we
could hear your music we could hear the
crowd screaming at you dude uh i feel i
feel amazing it was really cool and uh
yeah now i'm just i'm just hit stoned
i love it
um what's it like for you when you're up
on stage do you get nervous still or do
you just you just go up there um i i
always get nervous at like festivals
because you know i don't i don't really
know like there's a lot of people that's
probably not here for me so it's like
that's the pressure of like trying to
like
impress people that maybe don't know you
or like don't like you or something like
that that makes sense yeah but then when
people are actually singing your songs
back at you you realize you got a lot of
fans that's cool
right oh yes
you go hard when you're on stage like
you give it is that is that like fun do
you have a hard time coming down off
that after you finish
um
yeah definitely i think i don't know me
being on stage i just um that's like
where i get all my energy out because
i'm pretty i try to be pretty reserved
normally so then stage is like
yeah you let it all out yeah um you've
been nominated for three vmas which is
so exciting including song of the year
first day with justin bieber how cool is
that right on that's cool that's uh that
is that is dope
that is so exciting uh if you win how
are you gonna celebrate
i don't know man um
i don't know i'll probably just
i'll probably get some chocolate cake
wait the vmas are in new york right yeah
yeah i'll probably get some chocolate
cake from this one bakery that i really
like really chocolate cake is your yours
yeah i'm probably going to do that
anyway but
i don't know that's it so skip the
champagne just go for the chocolate cake
yeah i guess so oh it's a cool and all
but ah no this is great this is why we
can be friends i also love chocolate
cake so really you're cool yeah oh i
gotta recommend this this bakery it's
really dope i need names i need names me
too i forgot what it's called we'll
figure this out after um you have such
an incredibly loyal fan base does it
constantly surprise you how much people
are so invested in your life and your
music
um definitely i i think i talk about
this whole time with my friends um
it's funny because i
i don't know it's funny like feel just
feeling like a regular person and just
you know and uh having so many people
you know like
talk about like what you're doing on day
to day base so what's going on so that's
that's very
uh
it's very interesting for me to
experience but um
i'm i'm beyond grateful for everything
and i i genuinely think i do have the
best the best supporters in the entire
world and they're so
cool and they're really polite always
really sweet always really nice which is
what i love because it's not always the
way i interview a lot of people and uh
yeah that's not always the way so i i
love that yeah no all of my all yeah
they're all really sweet and really cool
so yeah you've had incredibly successful
collaborations with miley cyrus justin
bieber you know more we saw a picture
with you and post malone uh who else
would you love to collaborate with
um
there's a there's a i don't know there's
a whole bunch of people i mean tone
style that's one right now i would love
to do some stuff with them um
they're really tight
with their uh that album gone is really
dope so cool i've been yeah i've been
little that's maybe the only thing i've
been listening to while i've been out
here
well speaking of albums your fans cannot
wait for your new album kids are growing
up do we have a release date yet do we
know when this new album is coming out
um no i have no clue i don't that's not
even going to be the name anymore oh
really no not at all do you know the
name or you're not sure
i'm not sure you do know but you don't
tell me sure
is that true that is true
okay
did you just not like the original name
or or is your music changed
i guess yeah the music's changed i guess
since when i first started making it i
kind of
um as there's that and i just i don't
know my i i'm very like indecisive i
don't ever really know until the last
minute so i just kind of jumped the gun
and like announced all these names and
then i was like i don't like these so
that's kind of fun though keeps
everybody guessing which is always
exciting they're always waiting for that
next announcement from you sure okay so
the album coming up this year though
uh yeah it should it should i mean yeah
okay
yeah i don't see why not yeah all right
so let me ask we've been asking artists
uh this weekend oshiega is a party you
can just feel the energy the vibe what
is one thing that you think everyone
needs to have in their oshiega survival
kit to get through the weekend
you can say a shirt but you clearly
don't know
[Music]
um i don't know man i mean i i was i was
drinking some beer earlier i mean beer
would probably be my essential coming
here it's a really it's really nice it's
a really nice day it is lots of
beautiful scenery around so yeah
probably just drink a beer
okay how long are you saying montreal
for
i think i'm leaving at like 2 a.m oh
so have you been able to experience like
the poutine and the
guilty i went i went to a crazy place
last night me and my uh me and my
friends we were hungry at like 1am and
first of all i didn't even know so my
homie um dumb here and he was playing on
the stage next to me yeah i had no idea
that he was gonna be here and we're like
really good friends and i i literally
had no idea who's gonna be here until we
got here and he texted me he's like yo i
think we're all in montreal to girls
we're like no wait we all linked up we
were super hungry we'd all just got off
a flight and um we decided to go to this
place
uh i guess it's called duns it was like
it was open super late
and we went there and i had no idea what
like poutine was and um
and i pulled up and they were explaining
about like chips and gravy with cheese
and
i ended up getting chicken tenders
though oh but
sorry that i know that was that
insane
to get chicken tenders but um i'm
definitely open to some poop poutine
okay we gotta get this guy poutine stat
yes yes ma'am listen you are always so
memorable
first it was on the ground in your
closet now you have no shirt you gotta
step up your game next time interview
you know that right oh yeah gotta be
something else i don't know i just i
don't i don't even think about it i
didn't even i understand this was gonna
be a problem but no it's not oh oh okay
um you're so you're so talented can't
wait to see this new album can't wait to
hear all your new stuff seriously you're
so cool thank you very much